so we have Jessica Parker Kennedy in the
house today and you guys sent in your
Twitter question so we're gonna go
through the things you want to know with
Norah herself so thank you so much for
being here I am very excited about the
Internet's in knowledge and what they
want to know so the first one is from
Justin Gilmore @j Gil Yoda 900 he asks
what has been the most exciting thing
about being in the show so far
probably my supersuit and like working
with with with the flash because that's
cool to be like flashes my dad that's
awesome like I feel as it's almost as
excited about it as Nora does that's
perfect casting I just feel right then
Anthony at flash Titans ah he's a fan
well Nora start appreciating her parents
love for each other slash their
relationship knowing it was absent in
her future yeah I think she'll
appreciate it there's definitely
something funny going on right now
between her and her mom like she's very
much a daddy's girl and there's that
sense of like every time iris says
something she's like cool so right yeah
she sure Shui yeah she's just my
whatever so sure hi so um I think I
think there's there's a possibility for
that for sure but they need to like sort
out what the heck is going on yeah
they're not connecting
there's no synergy less energy like the
first episode was real tense yeah
real-time you and Candice just like at
odds yeah and it gets more intense yeah
there's your tease folks non-spoiler
more in tonight Anthony at flash paradox
asks what was your first reaction when
you saw your costume uh like very I was
like oh this will be cool this is cool
and then I put it on and I was like oh
I'm a superhero this is really really it
was it was I was definitely not
expecting to be so incredibly excited
about it and you've got a traditional
like superhero mask which I didn't
expect so when you have like this Silver
Age flavor meets the flash flavor like
it's a very specific tone yeah
see madam bus's has been so cool yes on
a bus driver it's it's you but it's
funny cuz it's driving so it's you guys
like flashing by which is the most
fitting to get that on video it's pretty
great just if you see it in LA
tweet address Instagram adjust the video
also grants mess
when he was scrolling to the covers I
was dying and he wrote the sweetest
thing he's like you're gonna fall in
love with Nora and I was Grant also like
sweetest human on the planet he's lovely
what really it's got a ginormous heart
he is the flash in case anyone didn't
know he's a honey
number four is from Kevin at all go
Queenie Toth was it more intimidating or
exciting for her to join in a
long-running superhero show with such a
passionate fan base intimidating
exciting of course but intimidating I
had one interview and the interviewer at
Comic Con was there together and they
view us said how are you are you
prepared for all the scrutiny and I was
like what is what what is that questions
in question I was like I know not now
bro now I okay but I've been really
lucky and haven't had too much negative
I think I did really really early on
actually I got a really funny message
before the first episode even aired that
said it was like get off the flash no
one likes you and I yeah I was I was
dying because no one likes you
like a fourth grader he's in the same
day yeah and I was like well yeah it was
just it was so funny I was like okay I
can handle it because that made me laugh
as long as they're stupid like that I
can yeah and I'm speaking of Comic Cons
is not here but the the coolest thing I
saw at Comic Con my whole comic-con was
when you guys did the signing booth
there were so many kid flashes that kept
stopping and each member of the cast and
you would like make sure everyone had
enough time yeah and there wasn't like
there was such a crazy line but everyone
was like no no this picture this
autograph this time yeah and I've not
seen a full cast do that yeah I think
it's it's really special when there's
like a lot of kids that love it and
every time I see a little girl dressed
up as Flash I like one burst out crying
and it's just it's I there's clearly an
impact like a really positive impact it
has on kids so it's nice to take the
time to to talk to them and be like
you're great and off that another non
question here Halloween now kids can
dress up as you yeah I thought about
there's a hell there's a costume that
you wear that is iconic then crazy
that's very cool that's pretty close you
get to be a hero to kids twice over
number six is from because number five I
can't ask because it could lead to a
spoil
not that kind of interviewer number six
is mr. mystery cell Aesir that is a
tricky name I hope I got somewhat right
we've heard the mother-daughter dynamic
begins to thaw soon so what is it like
crafting such a different equally
important relationship with Candice than
with grant I've literally just been
staring at mr. so it was like how am I
gonna let me just read this question
again and we've heard the
mother-daughter dynamic begins to thaw
soon so it's like girls yeah um yeah
it's been it's been really great because
I've we've spent a lot of time talking
to the talking to Todd really Todd
helping about exactly what that
relationship is gonna be and he's made
it very simple for us and explained it
very yeah very simply so it'll all I
can't talk about it
Cory yeah but it all at all you know it
it'll live off it'll evolve in a
direction in a director television love
that was that when you got the show
Bible was that cool to see the evolution
without spoilers was it like was that an
opportunity for you to talk to I know
directors changed per episode but the
writers was that something you got to as
an actress go like oh I see yeah yeah so
basically Todd how being sat me down and
was like this is your arc for the season
and I was like oh and so it is nice to
know exactly what's going on and I've
had to like call have a bunch and be
like can you swing this one more time
you see this thing one more time cuz you
know the world of yeah the clash is a
complicated and I sense there's time
travel there's so much going on at all
times yeah I've had to like really catch
up at the beautiful mind thing Colossus
at max 38 asked I'd like to thank
Jessica now that she's shot with the
cast and crew was there a synergy
between the cast after working together
for so long that you had to kind of
adapt to or to get into the rhythm of
the show or could you just fold into the
cast I fold it in really easily because
they oh they welcomed me with open arms
so they were incredibly kind and they
were like yeah it has been nothing but
positive 'ti and loveliness Carlos who
play Cisco came I was in my trailer the
other day signing posters for me I'm so
sweet for my family and he was like you
know if you ever need to like talk about
anything we're all here for you like
we're happy you're here and we've got
your back and I was just like thank you
so it's a lovely group the cast is the
characters they play because I hadn't
watched
nerd card revoke I'm sorry when I met
the cast I hadn't watched the show yet
I'm watching it now but I know I know I
know and each and every one of them now
that I see them saying lines are just
saying words but as them's like it there
so the cast
Carlos is yeah there's a part of them
for sure that that lives in each of them
each character lives in them first and
Ralph is disruptive like he looks like
it's insane that's the funniest person
I'd pretty much ever she's the first one
I met and I was like this I didn't even
know he was plastic man but I knew from
his energy yeah like he totally totally
he is like what lanky Lawson ridiculous
yeah he's wonderful
it's such a perfect cast for those in
the Internet your loyalty to the show is
deserve they're amazing
number eight is Marco Gonzalez says does
she have any favorite superheroes that
she'd want to share the screen with
whether it's Marvel DC just in general
any hero that you love to show the
screen um I'd love to share some time
with Thor in my life screen I I don't
know I I I'd love to be on Black
Lightning I think that shows dope and I
want to be in every episode of the new
Buffy that's coming out as Buffy I want
to be Buffy the title card Buffy be
Buffy Joss yeah and then our final
question is from randy q more at that
randy q more hey just love you on the
flash i have to say the charm energy and
excitement you bring to the show is pure
magic and in my opinion elevates the
flash in a major way
sorry not a question just wanted to
shout out your awesomeness so sweet so
lovely thank you that's it's a magical
show you do great work and it's in four
years of this amazing tight cast and you
did just pulled into it like it's really
cool to watch yeah I'm really grateful
to them for that that's totally on them
any anything you want to say to the fans
before we wrap up oh just thank you so
much for watching and thanks for your
positive comments I get these DMS and
everyone's always like I know you'll
never see this but and I do I read them
I see them I see them all so thank you
for them I've read every single one so I
really appreciate all the positive
feedback thank you so much for tuning in
as always if you like these kind of
videos do let us know check me out on
clutter heroes every week with a me
subscribe where this drops and if you
have questions for other people having
on the show tweet me and I'll try to
incorporate them into stuff and as
always thank you guys so much for being
positive and loving all nerdom like the
flash does positivity is where the
Internet can live I love you guys so
much to see you next time
you